we've all been here you want to stream a
show but when you go to load it it does
this in the age of high-speed Internet
the circle can be maddening but before
you call your provider know that you're
probably already paying for faster
internet speeds than you actually use
we'll explain this is your computer it
connects to your router your router is
one of many routers which make up your
providers network your providers network
is one of more than 70 thousand such
networks that make up the Internet when
you try to load a video or type really
anything into your browser your router
sends the request on a journey across
the internet often it's the journey back
where things can get a little
complicated and crowded imagine a
network of highways with delivery trucks
running across it
each of these are packets the basic unit
of Internet traffic some are Amazon some
are Netflix and some might be a photo
you're emailing to your aunt and they're
all taking different routes based on
agreements the network's have with each
other your video might be passed from
one network to another until it gets
back to you or the content provider
might pay a transit provider to carry
the request back either way it's sharing
the roads with a lot of other content so
there are plenty of places where things
can get jammed up anytime one network
hands-off content to another there's
potential for a traffic jam which can
slow down your video and cause a
spinning wheel the important thing to
understand is that you can't fix a
bottleneck out here by paying your
provider for higher speeds within your
own network your network is only
responsible for this leg of the journey
paying for faster internet just because
you encountered a spinning wheel is kind
of like getting a bigger driveway in
hopes you'll get to work faster so what
does all of this look like in real life
in real life these networks are made of
millions of miles of fiber and cable
running around the world and connecting
with each other in big data centers full
of servers here's an actual request for
the home page of a local broadcaster
Zeeland provided to us by researchers at
the University of Chicago it starts in
Vienna Virginia outside of Washington DC
with a horizon FiOS user and travels
across the country on Verizon's networks
in California it connects to a different
network which sends it to Austin Texas
and then back to California it then gets
handed to a transit provider which sends
it across the Pacific Ocean to Auckland
New Zealand it likely takes a similar
path back see all the opportunities for
traffic jams other trips have few or
even no handoffs powerful tech companies
like Google Netflix and Amazon and
content delivery networks have rolled
out thousands of servers spanning the
globe to get copies of popular content
closer to you smaller sites can rent
space from some of these companies to
speed up their journey here is a request
for Netflix comm that starts in Los
Angeles California it goes to a server
in kelipot RIA California that's it so
why do you sometimes get a spinning
wheel when you request content from
Netflix or other big tech companies well
sometimes their servers can crash and
cause an outage or maybe they took a
longer route that got congested but the
problem could be closer to home are you
trying to stream video during peak
evening hours and many networks you're
sharing bandwidth with your neighbors or
maybe it's your Wi-Fi
maybe you're leasing an out-of-date
modem or router from your provider that
isn't capable of receiving the speeds
you're paying for it might be worth an
upgrade you may also have an
interference problem from another device
like your neighbor's baby monitor or
maybe you're just too far away from your
router or it just could be your own
device are you using an old laptop or
phone or an outdated streaming box your
device could be slowing you down it
could help to restart your modem or
router or even invest in a better one
same for your devices but a lot is still
out of your control like if your
neighbor's son is downloading 15 video
games one night or a traffic jam out in
the Internet
so next time this happens and you call
your provider they'll likely try to sell
you more speed for your connection but
now you know better